[Musique]
premier conseil des ministres pour le
gouvernement belle isabelle borne
c'était une première pour la députée des
yvelines à yale brawn peavey désormais
ministre d outre mer et aussi pour
sylvie retailleau et ex présidente de
l'université paris saclay nommé à
l'enseignement supérieur et à la
recherche
autre nouveau pape ndiaye le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a choisi les
yvelines pour son premier déplacement il
s'est rendu au collège du bois dole de
conflans sainte honorine là où
enseignait samuel pâtit le professeur a
été assassiné le 16 octobre 2020 un
grand colloque sur la cybersécurité elle
était organisée au théâtre montansier
par le mouvement européen des yvelines
un sujet de société primordial pour les
particuliers les entreprises et les
collectivités locales depuis la crise
sanitaire le nombre de cyberattaques a
explosé il était très compliqué de
circuler en ile de france mercredi en
raison des départs pour le long week-end
de l'ascension attention si vous avez
prévu de revenir dimanche bison futé
voit noir au niveau national il est
conseillé de rouler avant midi dans la
région les bouchons sont prévus jusqu'au
moins 19 heures voire 20 heures et puis
le soulagement à jouars-pontchartrain
après 16 heures de recherches la mère de
famille de 44 ans portée disparue a été
retrouvée saine et sauve elle avait déjà
tenté de mettre fin à ses jours il ya
deux semaines un énorme dispositif a été
déployé par la gendarmerie avec
hélicoptère et chiens renifleurs une
centaine d'habitants a également prêté
main forte aux forces de l'ordre
[Musique]